ما سهله يا عنتي تكوني قاعده فيش حتى ولا
اخ ولا اخت باي حال عدت يا عيد هذه كلمات
ام شادي مسيحيه من غزه تزوجت وعاشت في بيت
ساحور حال في ليله الميلاد غابت البهجه
وحل الحزن والغضب استشهد شقيقها وشقيقتها
في قصف كنيسه في غزه وشقيق ثالث نتيجه
فقدان العلاج واكثر من 20 من الاقارب في
شهر واحد منذ ست سنوات تمنع من زياره
عائلتها في غزه وما فيش عيد اصلا ما ولا
هي هي شايفه عندي ولا شجر ولا شيء ولا
مستعده مش شهره بالعيد العيد انك تكوني
مبسوطه ومش فسك انا بدي هنا احط شجره
وانبسط واهلي هناك قاعدين بيتقتلوا مش سهل
كثير كثير
صعبه في شوارع بيت لحم لا شجره للميلاد
ولا ت للاعياد اطفال الكشافه دخلوا ساحه
كنيسه المهد يحملون الشعارات بدلا من
ادوات
العزف تقدموا موكب البطريرك الذي اصطحب
مندوبا عن الفاتيكان واطلق خلافا لما جرى
عليه العرف رسائل خرجت عن دائره التوقعات
شكلا
ومضمونه يجب وقف القصف وقف كل هذا العنف
وان يعود الناس الى بيوتهم احياء رغم انه
لم يعد لهم بيوت يجب اعاده بناء غزه ويجب
ان نكون موحدين مسلمين ومسيحيين في وجه
الشيطان العدو الذي يتربص بنا الملاك هو
تمثيل لكل شهداء فلسطين وبذ وبدلا من
الشجره مجسم ضخم يربط بين تاريخ ولاده
السيد المسيح الذي قتل في يوم ميلاده الاف
الاطفال وحاضر اليوم في غزه لون رمادي
يعكس وفق الفنان طارق لون غزه اليوم اللون
الرمادي هو الدمار اللون اللي طغى
على القصف والوحشيه الاسرائيليه في غزه
وفي
فلسطين المغاره عباره عن خارطه غزه اذا
بنشوفها من فوق النجمه منبثقه من صاروخ
اللي هي نجمه امل نجمه الميلاد مريم
العذراء حامله الطفل بحزن واللي هي تحاكي
كل امهات ش داء فلسطين خاصه في غزه في
ليله الميلاد كانت تعج هذه الساحه بفرق
موسيقيه والاف الزوار
والحجاج الاجانب
والفلسطينيين حتى اللونان الاخضر والاحمر
غابا وحل مكانهما لون الدمار في غزه وبدلا
من ترانيم العيد رفعت شعارات تطالب بوقف
حرب
الاباده في
غزه وفي قداس منتصف الليل خرجت الرسائل من
كنيسه
المهد رسائل تطالب بوقف الاباده الجماعيه
والتهجير القصري وبانها الحصار رسائل من
ارض الميلاد الى العالم الغربي على
الضمائر تصحو جفال بديري الجزيره بيت
لحم